hi I'm Amy Friedman I'm an English
professor at Temple University in
Philadelphia and my talk that you're
about to watch is called computational
satire humanities and it's a new field
and we're looking at code quantitative
measurements of the impacts of satire
and what do the humanities bring to the
computational enjoy hi welcome
I'm Amy Friedman and this is why women's
clothing has to have pockets this is why
we demand pockets so we can put our
microphone apparatus in our dress as we
prepare to give our first-ever talk at
the Wolfram thank you technology
conference and the newly introduced
thread of computational X apparently
some fairly large part of hell has
frozen over and I am here up on this
stage what I'm going to share is
computational satire humanities a brand
new academic area that I'm launching now
okay this is my abstract and yes I will
be reading a lot of what's on the text
there what's on the screen there are
rules about good and bad presentations
and number one is don't read to the
people what's on the screen I will be
reading to the people what's on the
screen so I have an upcoming book
actually it's it's out this week and I
talked about the importance of satire
literacy in the current cultural
political media climate and reference AB
and Iranian satirist who is currently in
exile in Singapore and he his statement
is political satire is often one of the
first targets and press crackdowns and
other attempts to limit political
freedom owing to it's critical
examination of power and authority as
such political satire can be regarded as
an index of freedom of the press when I
came across that I stopped because it
seemed I'd like the idea of a metric and
index something measurable is there
something quantitative that can be
pursued in in
in this humanities discussion which is
has always been considered to be a
qualitative motive assessment a
qualitative area of study
so this talk considers the some
approaches to quantitative analysis of
pushback I'm moving back and forth by
the way because I've noticed that when I
stand behind the computer I disappear
you can't see me and these this stage is
not equipped with the box that I need to
stand on so I'll just keep shifting back
and forth so my talk considers
approaches to analyzing quantitatively
push back directed towards satire
exploring possible metrics for measuring
the efficacy of satiric literature's of
resistance and the whole area of Khem
satire be a literature of resistance is
something that I address in my book so
it's something I've been thinking about
a lot I'm using Mathematica to try to
extend the modes of analysis currently
on offer and and I'm gonna be looking
briefly at some of the current excellent
textual analytical tools that one can
easily access my coding abilities are
nascent I don't know if anybody came to
the anybody else some of you came to the
really wonderful talk by the Maine Mintz
and Stella Mayman shared her code on the
screen and I thought crap my code is
gonna be on the screen and it looks like
I wrote it with a crayon hers is
gorgeous but I left it up here because I
actually want to demonstrate the the
learning trajectory that I'm undertaking
so my coding abilities are nascent but
my aim is to illustrate as strongly as
possible some of the types of queries
that drive the research of literature
scholars who rarely make an appearance
on this stage and which will inevitably
contribute to the future shape of the
evolving discipline of computational
humanities is writing the same as
writing code suppose you're asked to
teach a writing intensive class for a
university writing is one of the core
skills that we expect students to get
better at during an undergraduate
education I teach writing at each
college level composition I teach
literature studies most future employers
expect to hire graduates who can write
they will happily
in-house protocols and practices to new
hires but not writing skills I don't
know if you can see my little cartoon
writing is 90% procrastination and 30%
panic different academic disciplines use
writing differently
in the social sciences you'd expect to
use writing to record interviews data
findings and relevant connections to
extant research efforts in the lab
sciences which many of you practice
writing is the tool for recording
hypotheses steps and planned experiments
and empirical outcomes in the humanities
though writing is our process writing is
a means to articulate examine analyze
compare and contrast and most
importantly develop our ideas and
observations it is common to expect the
process of writing a project to have the
potential to reveal new ideas as we
write to enable the unfolding of new
connections and the generation of new
ideas I was experimenting with
background colors in humanities writing
is how we work in addition to ultimately
also being a record and a way to
communicate our work we do not have
proof of concept but we are okay with
that we just keep trying to generate new
and better questions
what is satire I made you a word cloud
so satire is a genre a mode a type of
literature and image satires method is
to attack using ridicule and you can
identify it in something that you're
reading or a film that you're watching
is is there a target of attack through
that's through the the method of
ridicule
sometimes satires funny but satire is
not the same thing as comedy and there
are two disparate areas literary satires
can be poetry prose graphic novels and
that's primarily what I work in is a
literature scholar cartoons represent a
lengthy satiric heritage today we have
to add modern media such as film video
mockumentary blogs and so on so I went
to Wikipedia and I made you this word
cloud satire at Wikipedia is primarily
satire then I added an extra empty slide
and then apparently twice I added
another word cloud
um Mathematica notebooks are full of
mystery has anybody else noticed this
and in a good way so I'm I made my own
word cloud that that comprises elements
of satire so that we're on the same
metaphorical page for what we're talking
about so the tools of satire burlesque
irony wit it's it's referential because
it always refers to something outside of
the text that it's attacking it may use
antithesis caricature it can be highly
erudite people can read satire and not
know that they're reading satire because
they may miss the reference so it
requires a bit of tuning in contextual
information it often references
historical specificities but in such a
way that it may resonate with current
events going on and so an older satire
still has relevance today and which is
why the study of satire tends to
eventually go back to classical writers
and then through a long heritage of
writers up till today
okay troublesome literary satire the
Rushdie affair what a lot of words I
wrote okay and that's some of my large
messy code even I can't read this it's
so small all right they're not many
extant metrics for examining the impacts
of satiric writing and satiric writing
of resistance as a measure for freedom
of expression but we can start with the
question of how to begin to measure the
impact of such writing Salman Rushdie's
satiric novel The Satanic Verses was
published in 1988 and almost immediately
encountered pushback for its satiric
content regarding its fictional origin
story of Islam many know that a fatwa
was issued against the author for this
book by the Supreme Leader of Iran on
the 14th of February 1989 so how much
did the banning of Salman Rushdie's The
Satanic Verses impact the world how can
one visualize this as a condition and as
a discussion and question generating
problem okay
my map is not showing any suggestions
okay I shall now evaluate the cells
starting from the top okay okay
I have many cells I shall continue
evaluating gosh this is fun now I do I
now I know why you people are so intent
on doing this all the time I don't even
have a cursor anymore oh oh my god
oh my god okay I take it back this stuff
is magic
all right and if we get that to go
animate okay there I made a map and what
comes up are the countries in the world
and at the top there's a box that has
the date and it indicates when was
Salman Rushdie's The Satanic Verses band
on a national level in in the world so I
had this question and then I was able to
address it in that way I'm probably
gonna have to do more evaluating so I
want to expand my question but in a
humanities manner what does the global
impact look like if I add to the
national level of book bannings of
Rushdie Satanic Verses
1988 to 89 the additional events which
the publication and subsequent
translation of the book prompted up to
1995 these events comprised book
burnings protests fire bombings attacks
on individuals and locations and
assassinations of translators and
editors oh the suspense all right I
believe I have to evaluate my cells
I'm evaluating myself this one okay all
right okay
everybody's so helpful okay okay oh no
that's wrong
okay I can do evaluate all how do you do
it value at all
okay input let's try that one
what previous step can I go back oh wait
wait
something's happening okay that's it
that's all I got okay see if it plays
okay so this is a an animation oh no
that's the same as the one before okay
it is the one before okay oh this one
okay oh okay okay
I don't know Oh teamwork awesome the
suspense is palpable okay so it's hung
up on something alright it did it caught
up there are people in this room who can
see the future
so what I was able to eventually
generate an image that conveys how much
of the world was impacted by the banning
of and subsequent events so the Rushdie
affair how did it impact the world
what's a picture what how does it give
me a snapshot of of what was going on at
that time so now I want to just briefly
touch on some other tools that exist for
digital humanities work there's the
happy trust that has this bookworm tool
and you can create a line graph showing
word use trends in thirteen point seven
million Hathi trust volumes so I created
a line graph showing word use trends in
thirteen point seven million HathiTrust
volumes I searched for satire and
censorship and I got I got colored lines
stretched out over dates and I
understand how this is a useful tool for
people who work in linguistics because
very often literature scholars do
things like this in pee and we say I
don't know what to do with this but okay
so there were words going in these
directions over this time period and
people say oh but that's very useful for
linguistics
but I don't do linguistics I would have
to go back and do a degree in
linguistics to be able to do something
with this so there are divisions and
specify specific swith in humanities
work but from the outside it probably
looks like we all do the same thing ie
we all ask the same kinds of questions
but we don't so this is nice it's a very
nice tool because when I need to look at
thirteen point seven million volumes
stretching from two thousand to
seventeen hundred and make colored lines
I know where to go this is voi ant tools
and it's I can input text or I can
reference a website and push a button
and then it produces all of this and I I
captured it like this because I get this
sense of small things and Oh total
overload of information working in this
in this milieu and I did spend quite a
bit of time poking around and trying
things out not all of these methods and
tools make sense to me because they seem
to represent quantitative analysis
deployed purely for the iteration of
quantitative analysis here are some
tools we made now what can you do with
them
my initial take is that they have been
deployed from the digital side of
digital humanities without much
consultation with the humanities side
I'm often not exactly sure what to do
with them this is a demonstration a
digital humanities query what can I
communicate about the current state of
censorship against satirical
publications in media and against
satirist s-- in the world today it
brings us back to the question in my
abstract how can I convey this
information in quantitative terms mmm I
want to consider events from 2018 to
2019 so that my focus remains current I
want to share a sense of an historical
moment which can generate new lines of
inquiry
so I read online a bit and I started to
notice a trend
the New York Times recorded sorry the
Washington Post recorded that the New
York Times had cut all political
cartoons and cartoonist they said are
not happy and then reading I found out
long time contribute contribute er
Patrick's a pet among others
got a weeks notice that cartoonist
contracts would be cut he's done a very
good TED talk about the power of
cartoons which I recommend and then I
kept reading and the New Statesman
recorded that that there had been a
public Ferrari I missed that I missed
the public Ferrari but the New York
Times ceased publishing political
cartoons altogether the Washington Post
declared that quote editorial cartoons
are democracies canary in a coalmine and
that goes back to this idea that
repression of satire is somehow related
to the our loss of freedoms of
expression freedom of the press and so
on so this is a Patrick tschappat
cartoon it's from a while ago but
considering the state of California at
the moment it's strikingly relevant ok
so my sources were the website for
reporters without borders and reading
newspaper reports about events that were
impacting satirist today so 2018 to 2019
is what I limited my searches to and I
was looking for material about attacks
on satiric writers cartoonists on
satiric publications on satiric radio
shows radio shows or entire stations
satiric television shows and and what I
found was a body of information pointing
out that satirist sin this period were
being detained imprisoned publications
were being obstructed radio was blocked
from broadcast television blocked from
broadcast newspapers satiric newspapers
are being shut down or newspapers that
publish the Tareq content satyrs were
being fired for producing satiric
content threatened and murdered ok it's
another map why is that so small
okay I know what to do
alright can I make that map bigger click
on it thank you says a voice that sounds
oddly familiar okay all right somehow I
didn't know you could still do all this
stuff when you were presenting on the
stage okay so so this is what I produced
there's a key down here
okay so darker Brown detained darker
violet imprisoned turquoise publication
obstructed light orange radio blocked
from broadcast Brown TV blocked from
broadcast blue newspaper shut down rose
color murdered olive green threatened
orange fired yes
okay my initial discoveries this map is
somewhat troubling there are incidents
of repression of satire in my global
hemisphere why are there incidents of
repression of satire in my global
Hemisphere
I expect phew I really anticipated few
because I assume a somewhat static
degree of freedom of expression in
certain countries so I resolved I must
look into this and how does this map
compare with my Rushdie map of satiric
repressions how can I demonstrate that
significant relationship stay tuned
what my initial inquiry opened up our
additional avenues of inquiry and new
new I was enabled in trying to represent
what would readily be qualitatively met
questions through quantitative means I
ended up opening up new avenues
different questions different approaches
which was kind of amazing
so my overall discoveries in general
code seems to be primarily outcome
oriented the correctly constructed code
produces a definitive end result rather
than being anticipated as potentially
generative of a new creative starting
point but writing code bringing the
quantitative to bear on qualitative
modes of analysis also prompts want to
formulate questions and radically new
ways and this energizes and innovates
established disciplinary practices and
this is a truly wonderful outcome and
one I kind of can't stress enough
because it's a it's very this is a new
area of academic enterprise for me to
step into and I wanted to leave all the
messiness and basicness of how I was
learning because I know I can make it go
away but but that's the process and also
having it there to me represents work
and thought and and the process so and
coming from a writing emphasis aplan
that emphasizes writing so much what we
try to to encourage in students is to
recognize that things don't turn out
perfectly on the page there's a process
of thinking and drafting and redrafting
and that and that that's all part of of
your writing but in a nutshell to be so
and
and inspired about one's discipline
after decades in one's discipline is an
incredible gift to be really revved up
and excited even though you've been in
this space this intellectual space for a
long time is quite something many of the
presentations delivered so far under the
rubric of computational humanities at
this conference denoted by the vibrant
violet color in the program have struck
a common note they have brought to this
event the incredible vivacity of arts
and culture and the inspiring
innovations of human centered
scholarship through Russell folt Smith's
investigations of art and AI this
morning jy nigger's narrative of using
code to incite awareness of creativity
in the study of math also this morning
and the mind altering mindfulness
explorations of Stella and Phillip
Mayman and in each case to which I'm
adding my own emphasis they have
stressed that humanities brings to
computation significantly different ways
of thinking and processing information
specific to the concept of writing i
tender the argument that computational
humanities needs to step in the
direction of acknowledging the role of
writing code as the generative tool that
writing words already comprises for
humanities scholars can computational
humanities develop to recognize the act
of writing code as a creative generative
developmental process rather than as a
means to reach and record desired
outcome
what can the role of code be to
illustrate and quantify abstract ideas
and real-world problems and to generate
new questions stay tuned thank you
[Applause]